Our mapper code creates variables that
we will use to create columns within
our database.
When we create a column, we must also
pass an attribute to that column.
Here are some column attributes that
we will be using in the activities in
lesson one.
We can specify a string, with
a specified maximum string length and
we can specify integers which are handy
for storing whole number values.
Relationships tell SQLAlchemy
the type of relationship one
table has to another.
Nullable is an attribute that
if set to false indicates that
a column entry must have a value in
order for the row to be created.
Setting primary key to true
indicates a value that we can use to
uniquely identify each row
of our database table.
And foreign key we can use to reference
a row in a different table provided that
a relation exists
between the two of them.
Inside each restaurant class, for now
we're just going to specify a name and
an ID number to reference
each restaurant.
We create a variable and
name it name, specify it as a column,
say that this column has a string with
a maximum length of 80 characters, and
set nullable equal to false.
Indicating that if name is not
filled out we can not create a new
restaurant row in this database.
Similarly, we'll create
a variable called id,
which we'll also specify as a column.
But this time we'll say it's
an integer instead of a string, and
set primary key to true.
Our menu items are going to have
a little bit more information.
Just like each restaurant,
each menu item needs to have a name.
We'll set nullable equal to false again,
to make sure that no one can
create a menu item without a name.
We'll create an id for each menu item
which is set to the primary key.
We'll create course, description and
price variables and
specify them all as strings.
I'm now going to create a variable
called restaurant_ID and
specify this as a foreign key integer.
This will create the foreign key
relationship between my menu item
class and my restaurant class.
Inside the foreign key I
specify restaurant.id.
This will say look inside
the restaurant table and
retrieve the ID number whenever
I ask for restaurant_id.
In this last line I'm creating
a variable called lowercase restaurant
which I'm saying is the relationship
between my class restaurant.